désormais visible du ciel sur la route
de la maison blanche le slogan
blacklight matters est le symbole de la
lutte contre la haine raciale et les
violences policières à l'initiative de
la mer de washington cette portion de
route sera même bientôt rebaptisé la
blake lively matters plaza je pense que
c'est génial
le fait que la ville les faits et que ce
soit si proche de l'endroit où se cache
le garçon au bunker je pense que c'est
assez symbolique
vous savez courir vers le président
toute sa haine je pense que c'est tout
simplement incroyable et merveilleux
c'est bouleversant en fait aux états
unis et partout dans le monde
trois mots sur toutes les banderoles sur
les visages parfois lévy noir compte
au départ c'est alicia garza
éditorialistes et militante qui lance un
hashtag mot clé sur internet
nous sommes le 13 juillet 2013 sous la
présidence obama
l'auteur vient d'apprendre
l'acquittement du meurtrier de très
bonnes martin un afro-américain de 17
ans elle publie un billet d'humeur black
people as love you à l'os à la vie ce
matin personne noire je vous aime je
nous aiment nos vies compte une artiste
et activiste patrice kahn que leur celui
répond blake lively matters le slogan
est lancé l'année suivante
eric garner et être anglais à new york
par un policier
michael braun d'un adolescent noir de 18
ans non-armés est abattu par un policier
blanc à ferguson dans le missouri
blacklight matters devient un mouvement
et organise ses premières manifestations
contre le racisme dans les forces de
l'ordre
suivent de nombreuses actions non
violentes des die in mettant en scène
des militants coucher au sol
l'occupation de centres commerciaux ou
encore le blocage de routes ou de train
[Musique]
je vais vous dire c'est un moment
historique un moment nécessaire nous a
tendu un moment comme celui ci où les
gens porterait enfin leur attention sur
les injustices m qui affecte et
affligent la communauté noire depuis
bien trop longtemps
depuis des générations et des
générations sur son site internet black
light matters se définit comme un
collectif de libérateur qui croient en
un mouvement inclusif sans figure
dirigeante ni structure organisée de
l'avis de nombreux observateurs il
s'agirait d'une mouvance un cri de
ralliement contre les injustices et la
discrimination
souvent comparé au mouvement des droits
civiques des années 60
blacklight matters inclut les luttes
contre d'autres formes de discrimination
l'idéologie de base vise à mettre fin à
la suprématie blanche
il est ouvert aux personnes queer
transgenres et si genre si à l'origine
il s'agit d'abord de lutter contre la
brutalité policière
sa portée plus large il reprend là où le
mouvement des droits civiques s'est
arrêté parmi les critiques certains
pointent une forme de radicalité en 2016
en particulier quand un réserviste noir
de l'armée américaine ouvre le feu sur
cinq policiers blancs en se réclamant de
blacklight matters à ce moment sont
créés les hashtag alive matters toutes
les vicomtes ou encore blue lines
amateurs en solidarité avec la police
un constat aujourd'hui blacklight
matters est scandé par toutes sortes de
personnes âges sexes et couleurs de peau
partout sur le globe